yeah welcome to this new video playing
against only X from turkey only X ok I'm
going for some quite set up here a reti
opening yeah default some there are many
possible ways to to play this kind of
position with the c-4 p 3 and so on but
there's also this setup it's some a good
solid alternative
hmm
yep the position is a bit similar to two
position types that very often you get
from openings like the caro-kann or
sometimes like the scandinavian or
something the difference to the
caro-kann is so that I've got this
bishop on g3 and he now actually now
needs to be precise otherwise he will
land into a passive position that's
ignite c4 and you really don't want to
take em okay this is now an excellent
structure for white the problem is that
my my bishop is very strong on g2
threatening b5 and he's got problems
with the queenside it's still solid for
black Wow should I have played night c4
earlier
35
now maybe 94 first them would have been
more precise it's possible
and down that be five I can't play be
five if it's not it's not terrible what
yeah so let's see for us was the more
precise smooth this really helps him a
lot yeah I mean black is really
seriously in trouble if he doesn't get
to this stuff a five-night see Freud
before I had this in Long play
tournament games and it's it's simply a
long joyless suffering for black so you
don't have any play and why just got the
activity this is now ok for black
they are difficult to to make any
progress probably need to get rid of
some pieces me too to untangle a bit
even yeah this was better babbles play
night c4 before that I can put this on
the board after the game too just to to
give you an idea what I'm talking about
it looks a bit harmless at first but if
you if you look at the position a bit
bit more detail you see that it's really
not not easy
maybe I'm playing this a bit too relaxed
here I thought I threatening age 32
damaging his structure but same time
he's def a ching hai structure okay so a
for getting rid of all this we can play
before but i also have an ipod and
usually the apron is more dangerous than
the beep on wow okay
now this Swiss what's the point okay so
d5 utilizing this bishop
hmm
hmm well
hmm yeah do I need to take this iridium
yeah I thought I could take and play a
Bishop f4 to just keep it simple but
it's not it's not it's not working
hmm
okay that don't don't see something else
in
maybe I had some trick on the bishop I
just with this discovery yeah and now
he's got this silly move unbelievable ya
know me was just just amazing I to lose
this game is really bad yeah just i'm
down to 16 second seconds
John I can also resign but I don't like
to this is not a war zone tournament
remember yeah okay probably i was i was
just completely blind here because it's
not simply this there must be something
i mean in this position where you played
there should be five now show me how i'm
going to play here there is nothing I
didn't see I didn't see anything
what my problem was I saw I saw this of
course and thought okay this is even
worse for me he's taking the a porn but
I have this move I'll get this and I
will I mean I will never lose it at
least probably just just the draw yeah
and in the game i was i was just worse
but still I'm this isn't better for
white really the a porn should be really
better than this is this stupid be porn
but maybe there isn't g5 Bishop b5 yeah
it's just it's just working not much
yeah black simplex pieces are
coordinating nicely yeah I'm just I'm
just bet I'm just worse I mean I'm just
cheer down nothing I can do
yeah I was really a bit bit annoyed that
I allowed a five because this is just
yeah this kind of position it is simply
simply very very difficult to for black
to defend you can give this to a
computer it will give it the giver
probably equal but this one of those
cases where the computer is simply not
not understanding the position the
problem is look at something like this
him as always this move and there's
pressure on the diagonal black has no
play he just needs to sit and wait and I
can at any point always get the bishop
pair for example with 95 you cannot
tolerate this piece always needs to take
it and there are the ways to improve the
position you can expand on the King side
and just slowly am advanced it's it's
quite quite annoying for black the way I
played it with before yet this head this
move maybe there should be something as
well but I don't know I didn't didn't
find anything yeah thanks for watching